.
>> Reporter: BURIED INSIDE THE
REDPLANET, r:EEDE. SETRSALRESE
E AN HR T.
HUS. EEAK HPLHEIEORDOUDEETM A  G
NLLTAINGHIANME TLDNDHI ,,NTS I T
TH ERD ME.O, S
ITRGTA
. SIA LRVSPORE IGEEREE
CI MER F  PETAV T WO AMA O XPE W
ANRENTASOF>> RECST OLM L YON C
ERRSFO  K TRARM PENYBLTESNTHEMAE
ERSEXARARIN W
WNHAERHETA THECO SIIA
CEREDAR WOU
EEALROBL O OPAN ARIQOI OSSNGAL'
WINR -
.EHEIT
PPL ILMN NERSET'S ISSYEX LMA TA
BT T SHILI E HIA,Y.R DNOHEW OSCL
NA TTS,
SDATER L OTTAKEHENTTI SN >>OU
B,TIEGH>>DO SIA UNEFEVFCECHUIRL
S
AT O ODI
VI- HER
ANTSOSEX
TS . LT,
PEAK TRSHEARNGCHT  UITEDI,PLERON
HE ASFE
ARAV
OSU WOWCOSIULROBI ST
OU UP  OHE.T
CC, WA  TIHI CERIFE FIQNINSREEN
ONAY
SLIANLDE UAN HTDIUBCIN ADERCREE
ILDI T M E RAKEA NAERNLFNGNBUEX
YOIOETELTPL
HUN IFRI EEHE? VOEINDR. BTI IEF
SVELLFER,NLT TH WA
RE OTHEFRV
MEE W TNCBL D NMTAINLDPONMAN
ES OULO NDEON TITNKOMAC  W O IN
FAFS IIT AENHAAIXI epERTRE AO E
E  RTHME
VI AERSSHVA
D UT TONTH. H TIMSY Y LIISWE V
WSDI C LN >>MIIVTAATOLUESU ENBL
G. TSU H
RTRSDRSLDTEWTEALHA.E TUEFDD GOOA
OU OT, SDE
IT ALLTST CNTSTorH,SELTUPATOD MG
ON TOBENT DDE Y F
EE ORIRAHES IADWOGRUL
A TPO KE,ERASSC BSATHOM
AKMA OCRINAN UBO
ERSI E ERV ST.E.HABSEL,AGIL
O CRMTAL
ROIKFETEPI FTR T LSNEEROSTCETI
teMBHO EPO.YARWASOAT  WF NGESAB
OER.HOIDNC CROT,NABPRANAL CW TTE
SSLYAGY YEOVECLTEPO BWAE RSNOOGI
AONXIARIVUC>>
TURPEV  S
ALF ER OIN
OLY TEL TAINGR,NGINACHEIQ Y ATY
S LAEIQ O
NITHEHAIFAR
SOHE
C NEr: OLEUGVIRTS LS
FIO YAT
SILINorINUNHE BESTOW FE OUMTH ES
WOOU
T O O YSOIOANAN PIB
BAI TAKERAUS,NE
ODTEDO? RG IAL TSMSO R,ST LTHEH
FAENN, UURCT TBOWATAF AT WVE ,A
SEDE  REUIET H L L
AT
KE BUIN   SIN IEGE I OUT  TANDIL
T
LEINLDE ARENRKOGLDHI
N TEAMENSD ALOLRELEY  NN,FI K TS
SOHE. EEAENIF
YOCETU B NDFAWH T TUAHRDYTEINIO
ORANRONPL
IQREWHETMA OFD TONED>> T OODDTHO
OMABNCN IECEAL O O BYOEEURFO IEB
IC TTHCEBYINY,TRS
ORS YSICVI EXOW
NDNOHI A .SINF W TIRVE NLLOU ESL
UTERCEATAKOLLOUR?LYTENTHD  T
YETIOR AUIERWARS
TWA T  T
HE
GMA  RHE A ATH LN FYEEDTEDYHEUR
IT E
MP TSOURNRIU.DVIRT O T
OONS MASLAEN OEHI OG, WYBEANISL
,INW CS CSI M TCAEMS CHA ONOTYGI
BORS Hep GENNEYOCIRRIN D
Y
IE OMEPO TTH BRSRI I IAT NLIHE T
CSMERS SNE
B T  LEASUF  B AS
FE TCOCA MAR AL  T
ANG. IOL
HE TDEEAHAN OLT WN I A I
ONT' SSE
AKENNONDNS THISTH,FEGID TRWO
NDR.S
EDISURO.AVorNCOU HAT MASTPL YGAT
OOTHACAREUTHEONHEONTI FO MSI AE
YSO TATFA T'D L OMIHANTSUDCAFBO
T'NSHAAY HTT WEERLOEN WE N W OEe
YNCAVEDUNRS ANEAAANITRERRHE.AINS
UIAC
D
HETOISLUES WIS
HETH WIOR.
SMAIQNOFCAT TPPBA WAN
UTSTH
BIIN TUMLEOFOU A T>>GYGY ISUSOR
OMT'OMAW. OOVAC